hello and welcome to this video playing
come Ramos with a black frequent a pond
I think I have a I have some kind of
memory that we tend to play the D for
994 no 9 a-4 huh and I think this one
but i'm not sure and then d3 set the
wrong moment to play Bishop g4 I don't
remember I don't remember I don't recall
that's Peter Gabriel right what song I
don't remember this song a song title ok
so what to do here normally we don't
want to give them the bishop pair ok I'm
doing this here I have a particular idea
to play with p3m okay so okay can go to
d3 of course him hmm sure yeah mm-hmm
came and saw them play here and just
play this position not ideal but i was
thinking be three but of course he can
go to d3 he doesn't have to allow
something like we should be one end pawn
to c4 I was a I was just a superficial
idea and now I have to fight against
this bishop pair without any particular
compensation hmm
okay I'm happy that he allows me to
trade that support this a little bit
okay I'm no problem can go to be 60 m
and B 6 and he goes Ruby should be 30
maybe okay I can take you fall in that
case probably
yeah I think I'm in time him Bishop g5
is an important important resource take
him
hmm now that is strong
wow that's strong should have played
that a bit cook am the only move I think
hmm Bishop yeah Bishop Bishop to g5
doesn't really net much at the end night
comes to d3 which is not not terrible at
least it's not mad in 93 hmm like to get
the bishop on that be 61 b6 here okay
Quincy to I will take and play we should
be six so what about this now queen I
can try to enter with the Queen and
night to be 2nite to see form always
have to make sure to have some some kind
of play against F to him I cannot play
like Bishop g4 Queenie 17 f6e we will
probably just take a five nie don't be
three is very securely protecting up to
okay
yeah but now i'm moving the Queen away
go into a seven or Queen to e7 let's see
Queenie 727 I guess 93 there's Queen
each form nights you for I just a tag f2
and you cannot defend it with it with a
decent move huh he still does it it's
surprising don't understand that okay or
is he just going 93-year but that cannot
be better for white okay hi morning take
it take here
Maria will be Jeff upon up myself check
sure I can perpetual him check I wonder
if I can play for a win I had a deep
part is also very very quick check check
I think I go for the draw him check out
wrong it's 30-something seconds and i
don't know maybe i can i can risk that
but 35 for 30 seconds I don't know the
computer wants to do this and says I'm
better yeah well it's possible it but
just just about just about and the thing
is check this is I mean it is I'm better
because I add some kind of they've been
winning this and have everything
protected here so even that is probably
still very likely a draw and I have no
time on the clock yum mmm the bit
surprising that unity allowed this still
your intention for jump probably
probably this is the best that I can get
they can get from here and deadlines
that i just showed the consent LOL chat
is of course at all so you can probably
continue to play this for win yeah with
hindsight i had some very weird idea
here my idea was to push be three but
it's it's simply not well that's
interesting and I thought this is the
move now the engine gives this after
which i think c4 is kind of kind of
interesting I mean he can't win the porn
him but he's playing without those two
pieces is that really okay I mean maybe
he can get an e5 later that said
certainly certainly a possibility move
the night away and play e5 so that this
can just can move again yeah probably
probably yeah I mean here I'm just a bit
worse I was actually happy that he that
he gave me that Bishop back something
like that was harm one yeah looked far
far trickier yeah Bishop e3 was a good
movement here why this better Jim and
here i think i can just about who would
it work with with what i have when i
played yeah at the enter end the draw
okay well i hope you liked it thanks for
watching